the time has come for 3g to pass on
3g network which means you can surf the
web some people will like finding their
way twice as fast can you hear me now
good
but before i had to say goodbye by
testing 3g one last time
i'm calling you on my iphone 3g on 3g
why did i do this because well
i love old tech but also because this
year the three big us cellular carriers
are sunsetting their once groundbreaking
3g networks att will be the first
hitting the 3g kill switch on february
22nd
the rest will be dead by december
they're all doing this to free up
spectrum for their 5g networks
even now you can't activate a 3g phone
on those networks something i learned
the hard way trying to get these two
phones to work in the last couple of
weeks this iphone 3g i got it handling
calls and texts on h2o wireless
and then this iphone 4 i finally got
working on cricut wireless for data but
3g service would get cut off every few
hours or so thank you for calling qriket
wireless and you're saying you want to
reactivate your life yes both qriket and
h2o wireless use the at t network but
the end of 3g is not just the end of
some network technology this is a moment
to remember that 3g really gave birth to
the modern day smartphone so i tried to
go back in time challenging myself to
use these old iphones on this old
network
mission 1 use the web to find a charger
so yeah this iphone 4 is constantly
dying
phone died again phone shut down again
phone's dead again phone shut down again
it works pretty well when it's plugged
in
so i went on a search for a new charger
best buy i miss that loading of the blue
bar
i won't make you wait it took the iphone
4 on 3g 39 seconds to load the site it
took the iphone 12 pro on 4g less than
five seconds
sure that's insanely slow and right now
these images don't load well because the
browser's so outdated and mobile
versions of websites today require more
bandwidth but you have to remember that
before 3g we had 2g or edge which was
fine for quickly getting texts and email
but horrible for loading web pages or
any other images we're off to the races
here
3g 2.8 times faster mission 2 get an
uber so this is sort of amazing this
iphone 4 running ios 5.1 from back in
2010 had the uber app installed i tried
logging in with my username and password
but first i got a lot of this
and then it says my uber account has
been disabled of course that has nothing
to do with 3g this version of the uber
app is old and it's not supported
anymore by the company
so i had to use my 5g iphone 12 to get
an uber it's a bummer because 3g was
actually crucial to getting new apps
like uber started so i called up someone
who had an insider view when the app
revolution was just getting started
hi ralph
yes hey it's joanna from the wall street
journal how are you
thank you
that's ralph de la vega he was the ceo
of att mobility when the first iphones
were introduced and were exclusive to
att when we met with the uber team and
they asked us to help them finance the
iphone that we're going to be giving to
the drivers they explain to us what they
were planning to do
with smartphones with mobile broadband
technology and with this amazing
easy-to-use interface that used the gps
capability on the iphone and it was an
aha moment mission three post a photo
so yes i finally made it to best buy
success of course i had to brag about it
by posting on social media
which was also fueled by the mobile
revolution
except yet again the instagram app was
too old and the website didn't load i
got luckier with facebook the upload
failed a few times why upload failed but
then i was finally able to get it to
work via the mobile facebook site but
remember this photo was small just 160
kilobytes
a selfie taken with the iphone 12 is
much bigger
look everyone 3g
3g woohoo
3g before it dies and this video wasn't
even hd let alone 4k
as smartphone cameras got better we also
got 4g which was even faster for all the
things photo and video
it also brought even better video
streaming and it's why around that time
we started to see bigger displays on our
phones
and that brings us full circle with 3g
going away making more room for 5g 3g
unlocked these new apps and gave us an
inkling of what we could do on our new
go anywhere pocket computers they also
made us realize that we needed speed and
4g made it all faster to do everything
else we do on our modern big screen
phones
5g is well 5g is supposed to do
something better than all that
technology with
faster download speeds
less latency and the accuracy to
pinpoint location even better than the
prior technologies tells me that we're
going to see another cycle of incredible
innovation
so thank you 3g
rest in peace
i will
kinda miss you
probably not
can i borrow your 5g phone
sure
thank you kenny
thank you 5g